tu dois saluer le génie je suis me
disais il faut ajouter près salim
moi je m'appelle et me sied sinaï la
méthode nessma tv ou ménez
ni burundi j'habitais à monica ma
province natale
tout cela est servi les desseins 10
juillet à bujumbura des beats by fils
m'a proposé de venir en france pour
accompagner son fils qui c'est qui est
indiquée ou du moins handicapé mais on
arrive à les montrer mon passeport aux
visites et coincé chez lui au dîner de
travail mais ça salaires
[Musique]
il m'a aidé j'étais comme eichmann les
esclaves
jérôme et tout faire mais tout fait tout
et avec qui sont inquiétés la maison la
dmr laver son fils qui handicape les la
prise il fait le bricolage la peinture
toute l'année mais ça mon pays je
travaillais c'était dur si c'était là où
j'ai dormi flash menacer ses ennemis il
n'y a ni chauffage et de l'eau mais à
côté du dakota et de chaudière qui a
malheureusement ils fuyaient le le film
et du gasoil
je cuisinais mais il ne me donnait rien
à manger
il m'a traité comme un animal comme je
n'ai pas retourné au burundi malgré
toutes les demandes et de retourner au
pays mais les rockies et du monde
dominée problème à mes amis aussi qu'il
me gros coup
j'ai dit à un vidéo sont ils prouvent
pour fuir mais jp la police estime aussi
la préhistoire attraper des rôles si tu
n'as pas les papiers il va te mettais en
prison je vous tenté de filmer je ne
connais pas ni personne pour parler en
france passe aujourd'hui par lots qni
j'ai hyper à ce jour l'affermage était
très très content ça m'a fait beaucoup
il est très grande joie
j'étais de l'île de man est très très
fatiguée ce jour là je n'ai pas de
revenir gens mais c'est vachement la
prochaine finale
d12 prison des couples je ne trouve pas
suffisant parce que moi j'ai vu qu'ils
disent sans voix les messins pas
m'occuper de ma famille qui dit j'aime
beaucoup
[Musique]
il faut qu'il est mauvais mais droit
toutes et toutes mes forces et j'ai
gâchis chez eux il faut qu'ils moquer
parce que j'en ai besoin
il m'a volé ma vie parce qu'il disait
qu'il était 6e au lieu de progresser à
et géraud qui lie du midi je sens bien
parce que je suis mais harry soins
phrase ils sont à l'école des faits le
couple français
ma femme et elle est aussi il va
commencer le cours d'eau français
bientôt donc été aussi il ya le courage
et puis va trouver jour ou du travail
donc on va commencer notre vie je
voulais moi vous ferez le côté de la
route
et puis pour être et chauffer les mains
jouées ce taxi comme ça mon avenir et
fauqué jeté d'huile du travail privé
airs et qu'il vive la france avec m
l'amour c'est ça qui unit les ombres
mais il faut pas fermer quelqu'un dans
le coin le mépriser ollier d'eau doivent
faire progresser le rabaisser neuf sa
séquence et papon il faut toujours vivre
dans l'amour et dans la liberté